I'm going to take a step away from major
football go into the world with high
school football and go to David Hall of
the Chicago Tribune and there's a very
good reason we're talking high school
football interesting scenario going on
right now between two schools Fenwick
and plainfield north in the state
playoffs in Illinois that's all the
setup you're getting David I want to
hear tell us tell us all about the
situation what happened at the end of
the game and why is this a national
story right now well the national story
because it speaks a lot more than just
two plays in the state finals there's a
lot of questions and issues about
sportsmanship and about just ethics and
and what is the right thing to do and
there's very good arguments on both
sides but the long story short Fenwick
was running out the clock they were had
10 27 in the semi-final against
plainfield north and they decided to
throw the ball down the field to no one
in particular to run out the last four
seconds of the game and they should have
probably taken safety there at the
15-yard line they could have run out the
clock they didn't they chose that route
the officials decided that that was
intentional grounding they awarded
plainfield north and untimed down he's
seen it before in Oklahoma State in
Central Michigan with the untimed down
and the penalty they take the field goal
that sent the game into overtime so what
you're saying is the call was correct
but the enforcement was incorrect well
the call was Craig because it was
intentional grounding yes the
enforcement of the rule was incorrect
and we would find that out later okay
the ihsa with the governing body for the
Illinois State athletics issued a
statement after the game apologizing to
Fenwick for the incorrect enforcement of
the rule out to the national federations
high school athletics says that you do
not award a nun time down in situation
like that so correct call wrong
enforcement and so that's how that's how
the game was won on that incorrect on
that incorrect well you know because in
over because in overtime plainfield
north went for two and got
call made it and they won 18 to 17 okay
so that how we are where we are what did
defend with team coaches and parents do
after the game well I wasn't there but
they were distraught from what I
understand they had gone from
celebrating you know in the state
championship game to you know kind of
process you know to what do these a lot
of these kids was a devastating defeat
you know the worst defeat of the season
arm a big range of emotions in the span
of a short period of time and plainfield
north celebrated like a team that had
just come back and got in the second
life and you know one chance to play for
the state title but the reason the
reason this is a story because it's of
the reaction or because the reaction
after the game is is there a lawsuit is
this in the courts now yes Benwick filed
suit there in court right now a judge is
deciding the fate of saturday state
final game it is a Senecas made to
margot made the argument that there's
precedent for the ihsa to overturn in
reverse the ruling because um the the
game was won on false pretenses the game
was won because it should have ended
it's a long haul it's a wrong call
yesterday the but what what options does
does a judge have right now now that
it's in his or her lap budge can say
that they can reverse the they can
overturn the outcome and declare fan
with the winner because the the
application of the rule incorrectly led
to provident are prob plainfield north
winning the game needs anyone locally
I'm sorry David is anyone locally
calling for playing field north to just
give up the victory yeah we wrote that I
wrote that this morning um we talked
about that what can really get uh you
know very split this is this is a
polarizing issue in Chicago we I wrote
it I wrote a column in this morning's
papers online yesterday on the radio for
four hours this morning there's
definitely a this resonates a lot of
people and there's very passionate
feelings on both sides of the issue if
there's a right thing to do is the
right thing for plainfield north to give
it up in your opinion I know you wrote
that article or is the right thing for
the the judge to make a call legally the
right thing in my opinion it's only my
opinion would have been for plainfield
north to to say I'm Sunday morning that
you know this is the ultimate show of
sportsmanship we did not earn this
victory we were the beneficiaries of a
bad Paul arm and this isn't a
pass-interference comes in quarter this
is in a holding call in the third this
is the last play of the game and the
last play of the game detect it
determine what happened in overtime and
that was the right things in my mind to
do is to say that they want the rightful
winners and then what should be the
deserving representative in the state
final game a couple of questions couple
of questions when is a ruling expected
and when is the state final game the
final game is saturday four o'clock and
champagne ruling that's a very good
question it's got to be sooner rather
than later both teams were practicing
last night I don't know what to expect
I'm not a legal expert and I don't play
one on TV but I don't know that we
haven't it we we know exactly when we're
going to get some clarification here
before I let you go gut feeling on what
you think is going to happen I know you
said feeling is going is probably going
to you know will uphold the status quo
and and I think that's going to be the
result of this even though there is some
precedent for overturning on ihsa ruling
and determining a new winner so we'll
see unprecedented situation different
kind of football story heading into a
great football weekend here thanksgiving
david la chicago tribune we appreciate
the inside thank you thank you the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]